the 5g wireless transformation requires
the right frequencies now low band radio
spectrum transmits small amounts of data
over long distances the hive and
transmits large amount of data over
short distances
now the mid band spectrum are so-called
Goldilocks frequencies such as the C
band they have the right combination of
both properties but it's in short supply
now 5g will allow wireless services to
carry more data faster using the C band
is the fastest way to make 5g available
in as many places as possible it's
essential for us leadership to harmonize
devices with global 5g standards now
satellite operators have this C band
spectrum and are willing to sell it so
it can be repurposed for 5g but seizing
this opportunity depends upon the FCC
the Federal Communications Commission it
has to move quickly to hold a public
auction in 2020 the FCC fails to act or
moves too slowly the US will lose the 5g
arrays to China 5g innovation investment
and jobs will go elsewhere should the
u.s. be the global leader in 5g
technologies let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI